if you're like me you remember sitting
with your friends in ventrilo playing
dota
[Music]
okay that's my mandated two seconds of
base hunter before i get copyright
struck and when i say dota i don't mean
dota 2. i mean the original defense of
the ancients a custom map for warcraft 3
and not reforged so when i heard netflix
was creating an anime surrounding this i
was like i don't mind if i do
in this video we'll be taking a look at
dota dragon's blood it's ending lore and
how everything fits together
so make sure to like and subscribe
because here we
go the final episode is titled game of
chess and it's more action-packed than
an episode of the queen's gambit kaden
continues his search for the dragon
knight davian who back in episode 1 was
infused with the soul of the dragon
slyrak you see a dragon
never dies and merely inhabits a new
host once its previous host has passed
on
in episode 1 the dragon slyrak fought
the dragon uldarak who was under the
control of a demon named terrorblade
terrorblade is one of the main villains
of the show and also happens to be a
playable character in dota 2 just like
davion
in dota lore terrorblade was sentenced
to spend eternity in foul fell
prison a place described as a hell
within hell
but he escaped and now seeks to shape
the world in his
image but back to kaiden he's a
legendary dragon slayer being the only
one to kill
all 8 types of dragons to put things in
perspective davion has only killed 5.
twenty years ago cadence saw how these
dragons can completely destroy
entire cities the dragon slyrak for
example killed hundreds and completely
destroyed the town of leithshim and
caden witnessed this atrocity firsthand
vowing to hunt the beast this is why he
hunts davion he knows the soul of this
dragon lives within him
meanwhile in night silver woods luna
visits the prisoner dreicy luna is the
goddess salameni's right-hand woman
carrying out her orders to attack the
various elven enclaves
this was all because of the oracle's
prophecy a prophecy which tells of the
stolen lotuses
the devil of the moon returning that's a
reference to the invoker who we'll get
to in a bit
and the end of all things prophecy goes
on to state that an elven legion will
kill her so she's afraid and decides to
strike
first so we have these two elven sides
the coriol tavi which reject the goddess
celemene
and the darkmoon order who worship her a
thousand years ago the sun eclipsed the
moon
turning it into a blood moon it made the
goddess of the moon amene weak and
celemene used this opportunity to trap
her becoming the darkmoon goddess
and punishing those who didn't believe
in her but before mene was trapped she
left a gift for her true believers
the lotuses and ancient stories say
quote when he lays the flowers on the
earth
mene will return we don't know who that
he
is in the statement but it could
possibly be the invoker or
davian davian the princess mirana and
her sidekick marcy arrived to the
darkmoon encampment with the box of
lotuses given to them by the invoker in
episode 3 the lotuses were stolen by a
corial tavi elf by the name of fimrin
the coriol tave believed that with the
lotuses they can find their home but
that's all they really have to go on
according to these ancient stories
which is why fimran seeks the help of
the invoker and elven sage of great
power
and wisdom a playable character in dota
2 the invoker is said to be a
quasi-ancient having
mastered a spell giving him long life in
the game it is said he is 100 times his
original age
the invoker has cast a spell on this box
containing the lotuses
it will only open if the goddess
salamene agrees to stop the war between
the elven enclaves but we'll get to how
this all fits into the invoker's master
plan
in a bit meanwhile davian practices a
speech on how to say goodbye to princess
mirana murana also a character in dota 2
was next in line for the solar throne
but surrendered her claim and
all titles when she devoted her life to
the goddess celemene this is why she's
known as
princess of the moon but also the
princess of nothing which happens to be
the title of episode 2.
miranda and davian have bonded over the
course of their journey and
before kissing him tells him he could
stay in the nightsilver woods and
perhaps the goddess could help him
remove the dragon bound to him it'll be
interesting to see what happens here
since we've seen how our boy davian is a
bit of a womanizer
a bit more clothing than the last time i
saw you hello beautiful
with the goddess salamani agreeing to
the invoker's terms the box opens
releasing the lotuses but this was all
part of the invoker's master plan
the moon eclipses essentially cutting
off celemene and her
powers from the people below dreycy's
prison for example disappears and luna
remarks how she can no longer feel the
goddess's presence
the crowd turns on the darkmoon soldiers
believing this is some sort of trick
and things get worse as terrorblade
unleashes his power turning elves to his
side and fighting celemene but how did
this happen
well a deal was struck between the
invoker and terrorblade seven
souls for one and that one soul the
invoker wants is
celemenes and the invoker used to be
lovers even having a daughter philomena
but the invoker took philomena to his
hidden tower when celemene demanded they
worship her when philomena gets sick
with a purple infection
the same purple infection we've seen
celemene give to her followers he
returns with their sick child
willing to do anything to save her even
swear his loyalty but it's actually
philomena who refuses to worship her
mother saying
i love you i won't worship you
the invoker believes celemeni
responsible for her daughter's death
it's the event that caused him to turn
from the radiant to the dire
for those unfamiliar with the game the
radiant is the side on the bottom left
of the map and the dire the top right
the beginning of episode 1 explains how
the world is essentially a battle
between
these two sides so the invoker wants
revenge on celemene
even willing to make a deal with
terrorblade to do so as the armies of
the coriol tavi and the darkmoon order
fight
so do luna and fimran luna was
responsible for killing finran's pod
pods are close-knit groups of lovers
common within the elven race
she attacks luna believing she's killed
her and denounces her former god
mene saying she's dead after all mene
wasn't there for her when her pod was
killed she had to seek revenge
for herself in the fray davion tries to
get to marana but is surrounded knowing
his only way to get to her is to take
off the dragon necklace which holds back
the dragon within and that's exactly
what he does and he morphs into slyvian
slivian is the name the closed captions
give to the hybrid of davian and slyrak
he's not fully davian and he's not fully
slyrak
this beast is insanely powerful and is
able to save miranda who takes off with
the injured luna but slivian is no match
for kaden kaden is able to trap the
creature and use some sort of potion to
return davion back to his normal self
caden doesn't kill dev in here rather
tells bram to take him home
this doesn't bode too well for davion
who we saw strung up by kaden back in
episode 4
caden likely wants to use davion to get
to slyrak
then there is also the irony of davian
being a dragon slayer getting infused
with the soul of a dragon his family was
also killed by dragons when he was young
and he has vowed to kill them ever since
fimran ends up taking davion's dragon
necklace so expect her to regroup with
davion in season 2.
plus she also leaves the coin given to
her by the invoker back in episode 6.
the invoker wanted fimran to return
davion to him after the box was given to
the darkmoon order but her leaving the
coin there suggests she may be done with
the invoker miranda also tends to luna
who is still alive it looks like miranda
will lead the darkmoon elves going
forward and she'll need luna their best
soldier
at the helm finally we get the invoker
saying the last line of the season to a
still living but badly beaten celemene
do you love me
this is a callback to episode 7 when she
asks the same thing of the invoker when
he pleads with her to save their child
do you love me
i love you it's not real love when
you're essentially forcing someone to
say it which is exactly what the invoker
is doing when he approaches celemene
whether or not celimany will say it i
guess we'll just have to wait for season
2. now as season 2 hasn't officially
been confirmed by netflix however
animatic editor robert meyer burnett
stated on a webcast that he's been
working on 24 episodes so it looks like
we'll at least be getting books 2 and 3.
i hope you'll like and subscribe as i
cover these shows thanks for watching
everyone for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram
at thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
you